When Stranger Things debuted on Netflix in
2016, it brought a brand-new generation of
bright young stars into the Hollywood spotlight.
The acclaimed sci-fi series continued this
pattern with its second season by tacking
new characters Max Mayfield and Billy Hargrove
onto the Stranger Things roster and giving
the actors who play them a shot at Netflix-backed
super-stardom.
The man behind the callous-yet-cool bad boy
Billy caught many fans' eyes on seasons 2
and 3.
And as Billy's personal arc became more complex,
his performance grew increasingly captivating.
"Looks like you got some fire in you after
all, huh?
I've been wanting to meet this King Steve
everybody's been telling me so much about."
Viewers couldn't help but feel that his striking
looks were oddly familiar.
So, who is the man behind Billy Hargrove?
He's Dacre Montgomery, an Australian actor
and poet who had only a handful of credits
under his belt before securing the role of
Billy on Stranger Things.
Though his filmography is short, there are
a few projects Montgomery has been in that
fans will recognize.
Born in Perth, Western Australia to Canadian
mother Judith Barrett-Lennard and New Zealander
father Scott Montgomery-Harvey, Montgomery
began pursuing acting when he was still a
child an interest partly fostered by his parents,
who were both in the film industry.
"My mom worked in the film industry for 20
years.
She was a production coordinator.
My dad's still a sound recordist, and um,
I'm lucky that I had that background to fall
in love with it."
He explained a little more about that background
in a March 2017 interview with Teen Vogue,
saying:
"They both worked behind the camera, so I
like to think that I have a really good understanding
of how all the parts of the puzzle come together
to make a film or TV show.
I always wanted to get into acting.
I've been pursuing that for a long time."
Montgomery continued to explore his passion
in his adolescence, then honed his talents
throughout his adulthood by completing an
acting degree through the Western Australian
Academy of Performing Arts at Edith Cowan
University.
This led Montgomery to roles in short films
like "Betrand the Terrible" and "Godot's Clinic,"
as well as the Australian flick A Few Less
Men, a follow-up to the comedy from Down Under
entitled A Few Best Men.
Those experiences then set him on the road
to a big break, which came with the 2017 Power
Rangers reboot.
Montgomery appeared as Jason Scott, better
known as the Red Ranger.
"It's morphin' time"
Audiences were so impressed with the new kid
on the block that they came together to vote
for him at the 2017 Teen Choice Awards.
For his performance as the Red Ranger, Montgomery
scored a nomination for Choice Sci-Fi Movie
Actor, but sadly lost out to Guardians of
the Galaxy Vol. 2 star Chris Pratt.
After taking a turn as the mighty morphin'
Power Ranger, Montgomery appeared as Jeremy
in the Christmas-themed horror pic Better
Watch Out, described by critics as, quote,
"an ingenious and efficient black-comic shocker"
bolstered by its charismatic cast.
Now, if Montgomery's screen work isn't the
reason why he looks so familiar to you, you
might be a music fiend with an affinity for
Australian music and a fantastic memory.
In 2015, Montgomery appeared in the music
video for "Old Souls" by Perth heavy metal
band Make Them Suffer.
He circled back to the music scene in 2017
for indie-folk group Angus & Julia Stone's
"Chateau" video.
Of course, Montgomery is best known as Billy
on Stranger Things, and Season 3 saw him display
a much wider range of talent that's sure to
keep him in Hollywood's eye for a long time
to come.
Next up for the actor is Justin Kurzel's film
True History of the Kelly Gang, so Montgomery's
mug will remain on screens everywhere for
the foreseeable future.
Staunch Montgomery fans can also tune into
the actor's podcast "DKMH," for which he collaborated
with musicians to bring his poetry to life.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.